imagine a pig farm and you probably
picture a scene like this at alder land
farm in new province Iowa you'll see
pigs in the pasture and feeding at a
trough maybe some chickens alongside
scratching in the dirt and of course a
big red barn summertime you got
knee-deep alfalfa you got a style laying
there and running nursing or pigs
continually alder land is part of an
diamond ranch a network of seven hundred
and twenty farms spread across Iowa and
Pennsylvania in reality the vast
majority of pig farms in the u.s. look
more like this at Brennaman pork sows
live inside alternating between pens for
gestation and Ferenc or giving birth
both have metal guards the first to keep
pigs from fighting with each other
the second to prevent them from
inadvertently lying down on their babies
once piglets are weaned they're fattened
up and covered pens in contrast to sign
on with Neyman farms like alder land
must conform to a 14-page list of
regulations among them pigs must be
raised on pasture or embedded pens
gestation and farrowing crates are
prohibited and Neyman will only buy pigs
that have never been given antibiotics
has truly done the old-fashioned way for
the old-fashioned flavor now that isn't
for everyone because it is more
expensive the animals grow slower that
limits alder Lance production to 1,200
pigs a year versus Brennaman which
raises 600,000 to sell to Tyson Foods
individual sales are less productive to
Alder lambs have half as many piglets
per litter as Brenneman's and if we did
the Neyman ranch style we would produce
a good 30 to 40 percent less every day
of the week so we won't even feed our
own country let alone export the
conventional industry dwarfs were
natural methods like diamonds 5 demand
from clients like Whole Foods Chipotle
and Shake Shack is growing quickly
we've role fortunate because as fast as
we recruit additional farms that's how
fast we sell it so the demand has
outstrip to supply for the last three
years Neyman expands 18 to 20 percent
annually a pace Swain calls manageable
given its rules that may be as fast as
it can grow much to the chagrin of
hungry customers